hello everybody I am here with Thomas
why nots Vaughn rosante did I get your
name right this time pretty high
practice I've actually I'm sitting here
with Thomas from the storytellers
channel a lot of people appreciated our
last video we did on Byrd box where we
kind of discussed the symbolism in Byrd
box and so we thought we'd try it again
and this time we're going to discuss the
symbolism of spider-man into the spider
verse
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
so maybe Thomas you can start us off and
give us maybe a very quick let's say
resume of the of the storage for people
who haven't seen it and want to be
spoiled give a kind of basic resume this
or anything we can get jump into the to
the symbolism right okay so I mean
technically is not our origin story like
we've seen before in spider-man but it's
with a bit of a twist or like a big
twist actually so I think the best way
that we can describe the story is a
coming-of-age story of this kid he's
called Miles Morales and he's a teen who
sort of needs to find his place in the
world he doesn't really have an identity
and he feels out of place in school and
in life in general and so he gets bitten
by you know the radioactive spider and
then shortly after he comes across the
sort of spider-man of this universe and
and a spider - fighting the villain
kingpin who is opening up a portal -
that opens up different dimensions or
like opens up this doorway for different
dimensions - to come into their universe
and so when this fight is going on
spider-man dies and then miles all the
sudden has to take up the torch and
basically become spider-man for his
universe and he has to go through a
journey of becoming spider-man and
finding his identity but then there's a
big surprise in the sense that he thinks
he's alone but now because this world
has been open all these various spider
people from other universes have come
into the universe and now they have to
sort of find out I have to fight the
villains you get it but also have to
find out sort of what makes fighter man
and spider-man and and have to go with
miles through his journey and that's
sort of the I think the main said not
synopsis of the story without getting
too many yeah no I think I think you
definitely gave the the right the right
definition of what the movie was about
and I think one of the things that
really hit me as I was watching it is
the movies really is about identity and
coming into an identity at first it's
about of obviously miles entering into
this identity of spider-man somehow
finding his way finding his own place in
that identity both being himself you
know not not just being having his own
particularity but
participating in that pattern of
spider-man whatever it is as we try to
figure out in the movie but then also I
think the movie is also much about
identity itself and what is first of all
it's a really about multiplicity in the
sense that you get this idea of diverse
spider-man and so there there's a it's
suggested as an infinite number of
spider-man you see that especially in
the Indus credit scene at the end where
you just see like these thousands and
thousands of Spiderman kind of coming at
you in different colors different
variations so there really is this idea
of a kind of multiplicity exploded where
there's an infinite amount of spider-man
and so it seems at first glance to play
up the postmodern notions of identity
fragmented identity and the idea of
diversity and multiplicity although the
speaking points that we hear in politics
but it's but what's interesting about it
is that it doesn't just play it in a
political way but it also at while it's
affirming this diversity it's also in a
certain manner reaffirming this idea of
identity that is all of these different
spider people are somehow participating
in the the pattern of spider-man you
could say whatever you know like this is
this mmm this story of spider-man and
all the characters are somehow attached
to it like a web and that and I think I
kind of think of identity as a web and
it's oh it's a perfect image for a
spider-man movie this notion that
there's something there's a logos in the
center you have an identity in essence
something which transcends your
particularity and it's hard to you can't
quantify it completely because that's
what it's not quantifiable it's it's
beyond quantity it's an it's a it's a
quality it's an essence and then you
have all the particularity which kind of
flow out of the out of that main pattern
and so in the story you see it right
away as the movie starts it's
interesting it plays off almost like you
know it has almost a mythological
structure which starts and it says all
right let's do this one last time and
then they tell you us the the basic
story of spider-man which we know to be
the story of spider-man and then from
then on it starts to tell you okay well
what if there's this variation
spider-man what if there's this
variation on spider-man would you still
write is it as spider-man and he just
keeps pushing you further and further
until there are some characters like the
manga there's one character that's a
manga girl from the year 3000 and and
she's actually doesn't have any powered
but her robot has the radioactive spider
inside and it's controlling it to have
spider-man powers it's like that's
pushing it really really far but somehow
because also it's participating in this
story of spider-man we we're capable of
recognizing it as being part of that
that web you could say so that's one
thing things that I saw I saw in that I
don't know if you noticed something
similar I think so I mean to me it
seemed like especially when when kingpin
he opens up that border London you see
all these various dimensions sort of
coming into into the world and all these
sort of strange forms starts take shape
and sort of the whole world is in a way
sort of flipped upside down mask this
portal is open and they make a little
joke as well about Modern Art where one
character it's like oh this is a Banksy
no I thought that was so funny I thought
yeah really
are they really knocking at Modern Art
because obviously it's all these modern
art shapes and they're suggesting that
this appearance of all these kind of
fragmented almost cubist and-and-and and
multicolored images are actually that
which will destroy the world I thought
it was hilarious that wasn't really
intentional I can but that was what I
got out of it as well I was really funny
so and in my sense it's like it that
image of the world that becomes sort of
this meaningless or incoherent blob is
sort of what's going on for four miles
as well at the beginning of the story
because he doesn't know his identity and
he's being pulled between his dad and
his uncle who are in their own sensible
or opposites as dad as a police officer
and he's really electric strict and he
wants to basically for miles and to sort
of his own image and and within what he
wants him to do and then his uncle is
like you know we find out later that
he's actually a super villain and he
lets miles do illegal things and he
wants to feel like the spray-painting
and like restricted parts of the metro
and so he's being pulled between these
two poles and he doesn't really know who
he is and
he's coming from two different cultures
as well so that's all going on and
that's reflected in the world I think
and then that's even increased even more
when the spider people will show up
and so it's like finding like okay so
Who am I and what is what a spider-man
and then it's it's by communicating or
like with these other spy to people and
and with himself that there's this sort
of where they learn from each other and
then eventually they find that essence
or like he finds that essence and he
finds himself in the center and and and
becomes fireman and again I think that
was really the powerful aspect the story
that comes up to this point where he has
to take his leap of faith and I think
you were talking about it before so
maybe you can elaborate a little bit
it's very what's interesting in the
story is that there's this strange
religious overtone in a lot of in my
videos and some of my videos I've been
talking about the problem of in relating
to John Rivera as well those of you who
some of you have been following John for
baekje
the problem of a story in which you can
participate because you know religious
stories from down Christianity is a
story in which you can you can enter
into the story and you can be you can
participate in the story and the
superhero story has been trying to have
let's say mythological structures it has
certain mythological structure but the
problem with the superhero story is that
we really can't participate in the story
you know because we don't have and it
what's funny about this movie is that
it's somehow suggesting that we should
that we could that it there's a a few
places in the in the movie where it says
something like everybody can wear the
mask and there's also an image of
Stanley where miles as Stanley does this
does the costume fit and then Stanley
looks at me it fits eventually as if
there but he can become a superhero but
obviously it's kind of it's kind of a
silly
it's got it becomes a kind of silly
parody of a religious story but it's
interesting because you can see in the
story that Myles has a kind of
converging experience right so Myles is
he has a fragmented identity he doesn't
know who he is like you said he's kind
of shifting between his father that's a
policeman doesn't like spider-man and
then is his uncle who's a who's kind of
like a player
she seems to have a kind of bachelor
player lifestyle but he's also and that
but actually being a criminal and so
then he has this conversion experience
something reaches out to him right this
this spider-man identity come it's like
almost like it's it's it's almost the
whole movie is very Protestant in the
sense that here's this grace that comes
in something that he can't that he
didn't ask for it comes in and touches
him he gets touched by spider-man and so
then he starts to discover that he
somehow weirdly you know connected to
this spider-man identity and somehow
this this spider-man identity is what's
going to show him his path and so the
whole thing and though he tries to do
things he can't do it he can't do it he
tries to be spider-man
he can't be spider-man and then finally
they tell him you know it's a have to
make a leap of faith like you have to
make this leap of faith and then you
need faith and you you enter into the to
the sea you're born again as fighter and
it's really eliris I was always like
John 3:16 for spider-man you know if you
believe then then you can participate in
the story so that was a kind of funny
little thing but it also it also does
show the the let's say the problem of
that of how it is that we participate in
our stories right and so what he's able
to do different from the other Spider
Man Spider people in the story is that
they are already spider people right by
virtue but he he kind of he kind of
become spider-man as we're watching the
story and so he starts as Miles Morales
and then he moves towards becoming his
own branch of the Spider Man pattern and
he does that interestingly enough by
reading spider-man comics and so in the
whole story there's a meta thing going
on where it's not just that you have all
these spider people happening but you
also have this different aspects of how
to tell stories which also come into the
come into the story so he's reading he's
reading spider-man comic books and the
images you see in the spider-man comics
are the original 1960s images of
spider-man
so like the actual actual origin of
spider-man in the spider-man grabbing
he's reading and he's like ok so what do
I do next right I'm reading the fighter
man comics so he goes up in the building
and he's
to swing across because that's what
Peter Parker does in the comic books and
though he's he as he's kind of as he's
Ria's he's learning about the spider-man
story he's slowly entering into the
story of spider-man into the pattern of
spider-man and then there's a meta thing
going on which is really fascinating to
me which is that the whole movie is also
about stories or about cultural
representation you could say and so
there's the the fact that the animation
style is also so shifty is part of the
the story so the animation style keeps
shifting between different styles even
within the same scene you get you have
different styles and animations
sometimes where you have a very
caricature all animation or a very
almost video game animation and then
you'll have a very realistic backdrop or
something like that so there's this like
there's this this disjuncture in the in
in the animation style but you also have
different types of stories so you have a
comic book you have the the film noir
still style storytelling the manga style
story cell and then you have you know
the Warner Brothers cartoon Bugs Bunny
Porky Pig type storytelling and then so
it's like all these types of stories
that are coming in and that are trying
to manifest the this the spider-man
pattern it's like well what spider-man
be like in a Warner Brothers cartoon
like what would spider-man be like if it
was in a manga universe and so it's not
just in the multiverse in a scientific
sense but the multiverse in the sense of
all the different ways in which we tell
stories are are showing us what
spider-man would look like in that in
that story so I thought that was a
really smart and fascinating way to kind
of approach it yeah I think they
actually hired a number of visual
artists who sort of one person would
then sketch out their style and then the
other person would then build on then
the other person would build on and it
sort of became this mash of all these
various styles that come together into
the spider verse you mentioned looks it
looks really cool and yeah I think it
definitely adds to the story that
they're trying to trying to tell in that
and and as well I think would to go back
to what you said about Miles his journey
he goes to the Stan Lee merchandise shop
for spite
he buys his first spider-man customer
outfit right and then it doesn't fit he
says something like it's no need the
homeless spider-man or like burned-out
Millennials firemen tell them that hey
listen you don't look so hot either kid
most superheroes don't wear their own
merch he doesn't has he doesn't have its
own identity yet then eventually he
actually gets his own costume at the
very end or his outfit and he mixes it
as well like it's the spider-man the
original spider-man costume but then he
gives his own sort of ornamental ain't
got his own style or his own yeah ride
this little the spray paint he puts on
and so I thought that was a nice touch
to sort of show that he has become a
center and in a way I need to come in in
line he's retraced his steps of
spider-man and he's now become become a
Spider Man like he's actively engaged in
the story he has art to play in the in
the pattern you know hmm
and and I think that that's really in
terms of trying to understand kind of
how identity works I think that that's I
think that this movie really does show
us and say how identity works even in
terms of a person so you could take the
whole story of spider-man and you could
bring it into a person right a human
being and so you have an identity you
have something which which is you which
is it actually kind of transcends your
particularities you don't totally have
access to that central person you know
the the the Christians would say
something like it's Christ in you or you
know the the the the Hindus have this
idea that you know that you are that you
have this divine spark or that you are
somehow you have something that's that
that's an identity which participates in
this kind of universal thing and so but
then the question is whence you when you
go through life there are all these
possibilities which appear in front of
you and those possibilities are kind of
asking you they're saying can I
participate in your identity right kid
am I able to participate it in in
Jonathan and you have to kind of answer
that and once you answer that then your
identity is going to apply itself to
that sphere so this is very sounds very
abstract but like imagine you could
all of a sudden you have this someone
brings the possibility in front of you
that maybe you could learn a musical
instrument it's like oh really that's is
that a possibility for me is that
something that I could I did that I
could join to and that could participate
in my become a branch of myself and for
some people the answer is no you're
never gonna play an instrument you it's
just not gonna happen right some people
yes a little bit and then for some
people it's yes a lot and then once you
enter into that then you will learn to
play an instrument you'll learn music
and you're it's going to be a place for
your identity to manifest itself so
you're going to end up playing music in
a certain manner which is going to while
being universal also be a particular
particularly yourself right it's going
to be you playing music and that's true
of any aspect of identity and it's also
true of
any identity that we participate in
right so the of course in this movie is
the pattern of Spider Man which is a
little bit of a silly a silly thing
although it's trying to be universal
which Alerus because it's you know like
anybody can be spider-man it's like no
and that's everybody gets bitten by a
radioactive spider it seems like the
radioactive spider seems to be one
essential part of the Spider Man pattern
at least all the spider-man that we saw
have some radioactive something but but
but but the idea is that you know if you
any identity will do so obviously the I
talked about part has been in the
Christian identity how am i a Christian
well that's going to be particularly to
you even though it's participating in
the universal structure it also will
maintain your particularity so you won't
be a carbon copy of every other every
other Christian just like all these
different spider people have their own
you know have their own flair and miles
the way that miles ends up being truly
spider-man is is at the moment where he
kind of able to have a balance between
the two between young spider-man but
also being miles not not not not being
something else right so he has you know
he and he finds that interesting balance
because he his father is you know the
the superorder character and then his
uncle is the the chaotic character and
so his his spider-man ends up being a
kind of gangster spider-man with spray
paint on it so he kind of finds his own
balance which would be different for
other people but he finds his own
balance to the manner in which he can
participate in that that that yeah yeah
I think you're right and I think to add
one thing to it is is that in his story
as he progresses like I think in at the
start any be towards the the midpoint is
well he's starting to sort of move
further away from his dad because his
connection of his dad isn't that good
and then eventually there's this point
where he he actually I think he tries to
calls dad and he hangs up and then he
decides to go to his uncle's place
because he feels like he has a more of a
connection to his uncle so he's being
more attracted to night of his yes
exactly pulled his side and he doesn't
know of course that he is the the
Prowler the super villain criminal at
that point and then eventually he
obviously finds out and then he
confronts him about it when he when the
prowl almost kills him and then he has
his own sort of moment then he obviously
dies and then it's I think the sadness
is in part of the fact that obviously
his uncle died but also it's that he's
moving in that direction that in the
sense that this person that he thought
that was a good person is actually a
criminal and and so I think the lesson
that he learns is that that one of the
Spiderman lesson is that with great
power comes great responsibility and so
it's uncle the opposite of that and so
that that's one of the things that he
learns to then become spider-man and
then in his what you said that moment
when he finally sort of accepts that or
like has that that that centeredness is
that when he's tied to Karin and his dad
tells him that he sees that spark in him
and then he finally lets go of his fear
and goes into that identity so yeah I
thought that he goes for all these sort
of trials where he is pulled towards
different identities and for some of
them he learns and the other is like
it's more for a cautionary tale so I
think how to handled it with the other
characters is well done as well and
there's also a whole aspect where he's
you see these spider people almost as a
and the community or as you know
as this as people who participate in the
same identity and and in command you
like as a basketball team right so
they're a basketball team and then Myles
is like I want to be part of your team
and they say well no you need to go
through this initiation you know if you
don't if you fail the initiation and you
can't be part of our teams like nothing
we don't like you and so they kind of
test them a few times they test them
they test and they test them it's like
oh you know it's like you know maybe
later maybe in the future you could be
part of our identity but now you can't
and so and so I thought that was a
really interesting idea like you really
see this group of spider people really
and and he's like trying to break in to
their to their to their group
participate in their story you could say
like like I always am I was talking
about and then finally he makes that
leap of faith and then he finds his way
into the into the community everybody
celebrates him and everybody he like
every American movie like everybody has
everybody applauds in work finally
coming into who he is and so yeah I
thought that that was I thought that
that was a very interesting way to show
so much yeah so many aspects of how you
become something like you said
especially in turn this uncle it seems
like the other spider people are
suggesting that part of the Spider Man
pattern has to be that you lose someone
in that in your story like they confirm
that like if you're gonna be a spider
person you know you you have to you have
to have lost someone yeah and that kind
of bring me to the last point which I
found the most interesting and one of
the most interesting in this story is
how obvious we take identity to be you
know even though we question it in our
culture even though we question in in
our narratives right now especially in
the postmodern world we take for granted
identity so much and in this story you
see the same thing when Spiderman enters
into this multi-dimensional machine he
gets pushed into this multi-dimensional
machine and that's what calls for it all
the spider people into this dimension
and kind of brings them in and so my
question right away when I saw that is
why do we think it's normal that it's
these spider people that come back
because obviously the person who went
into that - that machine that Peter
Parker has
multiple facets of his identity there's
so many aspects of his identity he's
Peter Parker he's he's uh he's a male
he's a you know European European
descent he's okay he's a journalist he's
all kinds of things right he has all
these identities one of his identity is
it spider-man so why is it that when he
goes into the machine it brings back all
these spider people yeah and that's when
you really realize to what extent we
take for granted this notion of essence
of a spiritual essence of something and
so he's actually it's it's the spiritual
essence of spider-man which is calling
forth all these spider people from all
these dimensions to come into the world
because there's no other way to say it
spider-man is not a the Spider Man is
not a thing it's not a it's not just a
it's not just a measure in the world
right it's a it's an equation of aspects
which a pattern of being which you
recognize and so the reason it's like
the reason why all the spider-man come
back in the machine is because this is
the spider-man story that's why you know
yeah it's a mess like that's why they're
this vitamin comeback is because we are
watching the story of spider-man
watching a documentary on a dandruff and
then like he would go in is like people
who have dandruff and if he had dandruff
people they would come you know it's
like there's so many aspects of a person
that exists why is it that that that
that thing and that's when you realize
that it is inevitable that we are
participating in stories and that we are
constantly referring to stories as
patterns in in as identities patterned
identities you could say well yeah
that's so I feel Thomas I am sorry it
doesn't matter you add more interesting
things to say I learned a lot here as
well I think I have one thing that I
wanted to say that was when I was
watching movie and I was thinking about
is like why with all the spider people
why is the story focused on wise
miles the main protagonist why isn't
that Gwenda spider-girl for instant like
why isn't it her origin story and then
with miles and all the other guys coming
in today it could like it seems like it
could have been all of those stories
really it doesn't really matter no it's
very important it's very important wise
yeah yeah no let me okay Greg yeah so
let me see if I if I got that right
before so I because I thought about is
like well he is as compared to all the
other characters he is the more like the
tricks or type of character where in the
sense that he is you know he's the odd
one out and he he's always trying to
sort of trick his way in the beginning
as well you can you can tell it because
he doesn't want to go to the sort of
privileged school that he's going to
he's actually very intelligent but he
just doesn't want to go and so he
actually tries to consciously flunk his
test so he can so he could seem dumb so
he could be thrown out and he's he's
this type of shapeshifter even in his
abilities he becomes invisible and you
can't shock people we don't expect it or
at the beginning he likes when and he
tries to sort of trick her with some
sort of like the weird yeah get her to
like her by just doing that and and so
he's doing all these all these sort of
shapeshifter things and and I think in
that way
he's also the person who can change
other people's minds and their direction
alive in the way that he sort of teaches
homeless spider-man or sort of
burned-out spider-man to sort of
revitalize his owns of being a
spider-man and the same thing happens in
lesser degrees to the other spider
people and so I feel like he in that
census is the the right sort of
character for for that type of story
where he needs to sort of revitalize his
world and also come into his own being a
fireman so that and especially because
the world is sort of turned upside down
with spider-man dying or sort of the
spider-man of the story dying and then
this all these this confusion all these
mixtures aspire people coming in that
that he would be the one to then flip it
back ya know I I think that that makes
total sense and also because unlike all
the other spider people in his world
because they're always saying there's
one there's all words one Ellen
like they keep repeating that in the
story and in the end it actually returns
to that right it actually it actually
returns to a place where each each
spider-man is one in their in their
universe every yeah but in this story
that's probably one of the reasons also
why this story is the one to bring all
the chaos is because there's actually a
there's actually a strange situation
where even before the the machine starts
bringing in all these multi-dimensional
things all of a sudden they're two
spider people in that story it's already
an anomaly he's already like this weird
anomaly where where he's at he's like
another spider-man and he's in the end
in the world so there there are two
spider-man in the in the same world and
so it's already a strange thing it's
almost as if he the fact that those two
spider not in terms of the actual story
tell me in terms of the symbolism says
if that's already starting to break down
the bright gala T because yeah like
there's this weird anomaly of this new
Spider Man that's not really Spider Man
but his spider-man and so it's like
that's that's the questions like how is
he Spider Man and that opens up the
floods of chaos like all this chaos
comes in it's like okay how how is he
spider-man he's not he is he's not he's
an indefinite character and the
trickster is part of that and so then
that we have to figure out how he fits
in the pattern so the whole story is
about how then does he actually become
spider-man but I think that that's
that's why he's like this weird anomaly
in a world where there are two right
away and then one dies and so it's like
you know everything everything's kind of
falling apart so but he's not spider-man
yet he's he's like he's like a
spider-man in training I guess yeah so I
think that that's part of but it's also
also it's also because they want to take
us on the journey of becoming spider-man
and so they they want to kind of take us
through this this this journey of him
entering into his identity and so they
take his character that's not quite
spider-man and then learns from the
story of spider-man to become spider-man
and it's different from the other spider
people because the other sighted people
they they were spider-man sure sure but
I mean they could have they could have
shown their origin story in
in in the movie ride like not receipt or
their origin stories through like the
the comic books but then you could have
just done the same thing for miles and
then had show the actual sort of origin
throughout the entire movie of one of
the other characters see you as a Myles
Myles learns to be spider-man by seeing
another spider-man whereas all the other
spider people didn't learn to be
spider-man by seeing others okay so it's
like it's like we're the ones who are
now entering into this story which
already exists and we're we're shown how
to kind of artistic it's like a
liturgically
it's like a liturgical spider-man movie
where it's like through liturgy through
this liturgical act like this like this
participative ritual he's earning you
spider-man and then going through the
different means and you know making a
leap of faith to become spider-man to
enter into that's right so it's it's it
really is it really is trying to create
a participative capacity to enter into
into this story that already exists so
it's it's he's different from the others
in that sense right right yeah yeah hope
that makes sense no yeah yeah it does
make sense I didn't think about that
well you know what I thought about that
before you asked the question and then
then I started thinking about all right
Thomas I think I think you're gone for
quite a while to an interpretation of a
movie so maybe tell people what you're
up to you because I didn't do that in
the last video I know your your work on
your channel maybe tell me what you're
up to and then we'll we'll end with that
all right well so currently I'm busy
with the series on on directors really
trying to find the essence of a certain
director so I recently made a video on
Damien Chazelle who who came out with
his most recent movies first man and I
thought it was really good but I got
sort of snubbed at the Oscar so I've
been I've been trying to sort of listen
to hundreds of interviews that sort of
fool all those put together what what
the essence is of what the director is
trying to do with with his or her movies
but right now I'm working on I don't
know I'm probably going to do something
about Game of Thrones before before it
comes out but besides that I'm usually
just I
do a video and then I'll have to think
about what I'm gonna do next with a
there's no set plan hey you should
people keep asking me to do something
about Game of Thrones but I don't watch
it I know someone asked for it Thomas do
it alright well thanks thanks for for
doing this with me it's as usual it's a
lot of fun and and everybody else I will
say thanks for paying attention and I'll
see you soon